on va revenir sur l'attentat d'aras qui
a eu lieu le 13 octobre dernier
aujourd'hui la mère du terroriste
Mohamed mogouov mogoukov a pris la
parole dans les médias pour la première
fois demande à être reconnu comme
victime et se désolidarise complètement
de cet attentat écoutez vous me direz ce
que vous en penseze trop choqué j'urais
pas pu
prévoir de ce que il peuvent passer cet
acte c'était trop horrible pour moi pour
n pour nous aussi pour nous tous Ctait
trop horrible comment on dit bien sûr je
con je pensais à sa famille sa
fille sa femme sa
mèreit trop mal c'était trop horrible
c'est comment elle peut faire c'était
son prof aussi je veux pas lui voir
aucun contact avec lui je je reconnais
pas mon fils c'est
pas c'est pas mon fils
ouis moi je suis assez choqué de cette
demande pour moi les les vraies victimes
c'est le professeur assassiné et sa
famille alors quelle demande à être
reconnu victime je trouve que c'est une
stratégie Cyril parce que elle n'a pas
dénoncé avant même si la situation
familiale était compliquée jamais elle
ne s'est élevé contre la radicalisation
des uns et des autres dans la famille et
là comme elle est sous menace d'qtf et
qu'elle veut récupérer la garde de sa
plus jeune fille la voilà qui se
victimise et qui adopte une stratégie
moi je suis choqué je suis choqué je
trouve ça indesscant oui peut pas
laisser le bénéfice peut-être d'une mère
qui VE récupérer sa fille de 8 10 ans 8
ou 10 ans sa fille elle peut se
désolariser de son fils espèce de je
vais pas l'insulter mais il a 20 ans il
est responsable on va s'occuper de lui
c'est ça l'histoire elle elle elle a
quoi avir là-dedans a quoi avir
là-dedans elle ve récupérer sa fille
c'est sa mère mais alors demain si
demain si demain tu as tro enfants
attends je fin si demain tu as trois
enfants si demain tu as trois enfants
trois petits enfants et ton fils il fait
une dingerie et ton fils il fait une
dinguerie et on t'enlève la garde de tes
enfants et on dit on on te met
responsable de ce qu' a fait ton fils
qui 20 ans c'est c'est le c'est ton fils
de 20 ans qu'il faut punir pendant 18
ans je suis censé l'avoir élevéjàc ou
oui oui alors si on est pas mieux que
tout monde des fois on élève mal des
fois tu peux pas savoir oui JAC
symboliquement ça me gêne qu'elle soit
reconnue ou qu'elle puisse être reconnue
comme comme comme partie civile euh en
revanche et donc comme victime avec un
statut de victime en revanche je trouve
qu'il faudrait essayer de trouver un
statut particulier parce que il y a elle
veut marquer une rupture après ce qui
s'est passé et on sait que dans cette
famille les choses sont compliquées
parce que la fille était en effet sous
la
mauvaiseêes pas courageux là mais si
courageux fa trouver un
truc autre chose parce que c'est quand
même quelqu'un qui a un moment donné
veut marquer sa différence et veut d'une
certaine façon voilà dit que le père
était sousemprisere c'est le père qui
foutit le bordel t elle tente
d'expliquer la radicalisation de son
fils déclarant qu'il ne se parlait pas
et que ce dernier pouvait même parfois
se montrer AG agressif avec elle
regardez peutre elle était influencé par
Internet par quelques gens par son père
je sais pas ce que vous nous dites c'est
que votre fils il vous parlait plus
beaucoup enfin vous aviez plus trop vous
viviez avec lu elle me traitait parfois
tuas République toi tu as mes crayons
toi tu as sorti religion il beaucoup
traités il vous il vous insulait
beaucoup sur le domaine de la religion
en fait ouais je suis victime
après mariage avec leur père je suis
victime depuis tout ça depuis ça fait
presque 20 ans je suis
victime qu'on met moi je mets pas en
doute que cette dame se sente
effectivement une victime ça c'est pas
le problème effectivement visiblement
elle était sous l'emprise de ses de ses
garçons dont un qui était déjà en prison
et elle avait la difficulté à s'extirper
de ça et cetera moi ce que je remets en
cause c'est le fait qu'elle veuille être
parti civile dans cette histoire parce
que de facto on va la considérer comme
victime au même niveau que les parents
que la famille de celui qu'on a tué et
donc moi je c'est une victime mais ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas la même victime
que la famille qui se constitue parti
civile et qui elle a perdu son mari son
mari son père son fils tu comprends ce
que je ve dire c'est pour ça je parla
d'un statut particulier tout à l'heure
en Italie dans des dans C dans les dans
les enquêtes contre la mafia on a des on
a des il y a des cas particuliers pour
tous ceux qui sont des témoins qui sont
des témoins de moralité qui apportent
des éléments à l'enquête qui ont été et
qui peuvent dénoncer des gens de leur
famille il considéré et protégé par la
justice un peu à part pour moi elle
pourrait avoir ce type de de de serait
d'ailleurs alors en fait c'est toujours
la même question c'est oui les parents
sont responsables de l'éducation de
leurs enfants mais pour autant les
actions des enfants et ben les parents N
sont pas toujours responsable et et
c'est toujours ça c'est on peut avoir
plusieurs enfants et et dans le l'au a
une mauvaise graine et on est on n'est
pas responsable de ça parce que même
avec la même éducation ça ne marche pas
parce que sinon vous allez dire que les
violeurs les terroristes et les tueurs
c'est de père en fils génétique
demand elle demande à être reconnu comme
victime vous trouvez ça
ind pas ind
d'elle soit au même niveau que les
autr ENF je comprends
pas on va voir ce qu'elle a dit elle
explique comment elle a appris que son
fils était à
l'origine j'ai vite fa ouvri
suractualité dans mon portable j'ai vu
titre comme un Chen fait quelques chose
grave en gbeta
race je dis oh là là je dis j'ai je j'ai
pas bien dans chtien encore j'ai dis je
pensais à
d'autres truc d'autres choses quand
s'est passé avec d'autres profs et vous
avez compris que c'était Mohamed à quel
moment non non non j'ai j'ai jamais
pensé si mon fils il peut faire passer
cet acte comme ça j'ai allumé vite fait
télé j'ai connu mon fils oui que j'ai
connu mon fils avec son veste gris ah
oui c'est aussi une victime en fait
terroriste d'as dem demande à être
reconnu comme une victime trouve ça
trouvez-vous ça ind descent moi j'ai
qu'une réponse à finir oui si moi je
donne mon avis oui c'est complètement
DESC pour la
famille excusez-moi ça se pose la
question ne se pose même pas après la
question de cette femme moi je sais
qu'il y a une une voisine qui a témoigné
ouielle é B par F et cherch au CAF parce
qu'en fait le problème c'est qu'elle
prenait des des comment des distances
avec la religion et que son fils était
téléguidé par le père qui a été expulsé
lui il y a quelques années donc on ne
remet pas en cause le fait que cette
femme voilà est peut-être victime de sa
famille de son mari mais c'est ind
desent de mettre même enfin je me mets à
la place de la famille de Dominique
Bernard mets-toi à la place jour au
lendemain t du jour au lendemain tu
apprends que ton fils est est un
terroriste toute ta famille s'est foutu
le le nom est sal le Tr mais êtrenu comm
uneis cette maman elle a éduqué ce ce
jeune ce jeune
homme qu' pren la parole et qu'elle
disent je me désolidarise de mon fils je
ne suis pas responsable je ne le
reconnais pas c'est pas comme ça que je
l'ai levé ce ne sont pas maleur c'est
qu'elle a fait c'est formidable mais
qu'en revanche elle aille demander à
être parti civile sur le même banc que
les parents que la fille que que les
filles et que la femme de celui qui a
été tué là c'est
compliqué RUP sa fille c'est la
stratégie seul moyen qu' de récupérer sa
fille qui a été placé me alors on la met
en T le 30
ans voilà c'est de la stratégie dire moi
moi moi comme a dit Valérie qu'elle
qu'elle dise voilà qu'elle soit pas
responsable des actes de son fils oui
mais qu'elle demande à être considéré
comme victime je suis pas d'accord
Géraldine non mais le problème c'est
qu'en fait on est dans un état de droit
et en fait vous vous réagissez avec
émotion et avec colère ce que je peux
tout à fait comprendre parce que je suis
dans l'émotion et je suis dans la colère
donc soit aujourd'hui nos démocraties et
nos valeurs elles sont mises à rue
d'épreuves donc soit enfin j'estime que
soit on en fait on je perds le fil de ce
que je voulais dire parce que je suis
touchée par le destin de cette femme non
ouai en fait moi je je pense qu'elle est
sincère cette femme je pense qu'elle est
sincère oui mais le problème c'est que
si on la considère pas comme une victime
ça veut dire qu'on lui dit tu dégages on
croit pas à ta parole on croit pas à ta
résilience on croit pas à ta
réconciliation et peut-être que c'est ça
l'issue du truc pour déradicaliser les
gens et pour que les gens ils ont ils
aent confiance en notre force et en
notre démocratie on pe le dire ouais en
fait nous quand on tu te désolidarises
de ton fils qui est un terroriste ben
nous à ce momentl nous nos valeurs notre
France on te tend la main parce qu'on
croit en ta
parole cré un statut de témoins
protégé d'ç LZ ce qu' dit son père le
père de la regard
bien très très difficile comprendre moi
aussi je comprends pas parce que comme
je disais àant j'ai été choqué
aujourd'hui oui ce qu'il a fait c'est
inacceptable ce qu'il a fait il a elle
m'a fait elle m'a pas résolu aucun
problème il m'a fait plus de problème
apporté à plus de problème et moi je
suis première choqué etarrive pas à
comprendre alors il y a aussi selon le
père du du terroriste d'as son fils est
passé à l'AE à cause de la folie la
politique française contre l'islam et le
fait que la mère de Mohamed mogutchkov
s'est éloigné de l'Islam a retiré son VO
ça voyez bien qu'il faut luire la main
évidemment que c'est une victime
évidemment que c'est une victime de
l'islamisme personne chante la marseill
tout en de
dire teror peut-re qu'il faut changer ça
justement pour la réconciliation
justement quand il a parce que quand il
y a des musulmans qui sont clair net et
précis et qui se désolidarisent alors
que là il y a vraiment eu un terrorisme
un terroriste et ben je trouve que c'est
hyper important à condition qu' soit pas
placé au même plan que la j'ai
l'imession
encme et pourquoi pas sa vie elle a été
dévastée aussi c'est une victime
collatérale quelque part on voit bien
qu'elle vit dans la honte contrairement
au père elle témigne à visage masqué
parce que je pense qu'elle est couverte
de honte elle ne sait plus quoi faire sa
famille est dévastée son image dans la
société comment va faire cette femme si
elle a un travail pour vivre en société
si ton fils est un terroriste donc oui
c'est une victime collatérale et je
trouve qu'il y a un raccourci un peu
dégueulasse qui consiste à dire que
toute la famille de ce terroriste
terroriste serait des terroristes et
devrait prendre perpète comme lui qui a
perpétré l'attent
voir c'est grave ce que tu dis si tu
nous fais passer pour je suis désolé
c'est pas du tout ce que moi
n d'c on TR ind cettene so considér
comme vitime mêmere
% on va pass on va passer un